it's too dangerous Minh I need to go
alone we're all in this to lead
we've got friends out there
but people will fight if we leave them
they've taken enough of us now we take
the war to them
let the final battle
[Music]
again
starwars the rise of Skywalker get
tickets now
let the final battle begin
we won't surrender we make our last
stand
starwars the rise of Skywalker get
tickets now
please pastime all we know the thousand
generations live in you now but this is
your side
on December 20th
this saga
we'll end
[Applause]
[Music]
let the final battle
again
starwars the rise of Skywalker get
tickets now
I know
they fly now
confronting fear
it's the destiny of a Jedi
your destiny
[Music]
it's okay that we're here it's okay that
you're here it's good to see you that to
us
starwars the rise of Skywalker get
tickets now
this will be the final word
in the story of Skywalker
[Music]
[Music]
starwars the rise of Skywalker get
tickets now confronting fear it's the
destiny of a Jedi your destiny if this
mission fails it was all for nothing
[Music]
we're not alone good people will fight
if we lead them
[Music]
y'all do that you he does it see
star wars arise up Skywalker tickets
available now
oh we've done all this time we're doing
their Threepio taking one last look sir
at my friend
confronting fear
is the destiny of a Jedi
your destiny
we're all in this
command star wars the rise of Skywalker
tickets available now
you